Hey, Darius is reading his protective order from Zena. This man,
this man needs help. This man needs help. Get him help. Get him
help. This man is not
No way. Does he think he looks good in a lot of these videos?
>> Wait, which one of these is lies?
This sounds like a lot of from Zena. Wait. Uh, could you just
say no? I did. Oh my goodness. I don't remember that. I don't
remember that. There's no way a is trying to take GMO. That would
be that's too far. Is >> Why did he read that as if it
was an unreasonable request? He just read that like, uh, what?
What? That's crazy. Why would you ask me to stop doing that?
We'll talk to you later. Bye. >> Yeah. Bye.
>> Okay. Darius is reading his protective order from Zena.
>> Do not commit further acts of sexual assault or abuse.
Why did he read that as if it was an unreasonable request? He
just read that like, uh, what? What?
That's crazy. Why would you ask me to stop doing that? >> Oh,
I have her address. That's good, I guess. Suspend. The applicant
further asked the court to suspend the respondent's license to
carry a handgun. >> Bro, you don't even have a gun. >> Oh
my god.
Prohibit the respondent from taking, harming, or interfering
with the care, custody, or control of the following pet. And
her response to
>> what? Hold on.
There's no way a is trying to take GMO. That would be that's
too far. >> Is we have dog cat in the house and use mace
and tear gas bombs. >> No way. Oh, that's rough. >> Oh
my god. Prohibit the respondent from taking, harming, or interfering
with the care, custody, or control of the following pet. And
her response to is we have dogs and cats in the house and use
>> Oh, did did she filled out a form and this was the part
of the form? >> Tear gas bombs. That's what she wrote
cuz she thinks we're going to tear gas her. We thought that we
could be current
Something. Oh, she kept her phone number the same.
No. What did she say happened? I live stream and I have several
videos of him stalking me and following me and physically assaulting
me. I also now have a case in fluger after he spit on me and
insulted me and I pressed charges. The citation number is XYZ.
He has since contacted me off fake text app numbers and via Discord
in various communities I am in in order to get my attention.
He has visibly assaulted friends I am with as well. Hey, at least
you didn't call him a boyfriend. >> This man This man needs
help. This man needs help. Get him help. Get him help.
This man is not okay.
Oh, there's no way. >> Was a weapon involved? Selfie stick
and glass cup. Zena is the one who hit me with the glass cup
during that. Did anyone call the police? Yes, I pressed charges,
but he was not arrested. I called the police,
but she did, too. Were you injured? Yes. He bit both my breast
and fingers until I bled. The cops took pictures. She was on
top of
>> Uh, could you just say no, I did? Oh my goodness. I
don't remember that. I don't remember that. has respondent >> He
is a biter. This is true. >> On or around 5:22 52 Darius
stalked me to Dallas, Texas and physically assaulted me on video
with documented evidence. He continued to follow me around various
buildings and continued to assault on me and various threats.
>> This is This is talking about TwitchCon,
>> Continued to stalk me via social media and speak about
me and have people contact me for him. When have I done
He even joined a public event I was hosting just >> um
no I haven't had people contact you for me >> be around
me to harass me again which is on video as well. Is she talking
about the prison stream? On July 4th he continued the assault
by arriving at another event he knew I was attending where he
continued to approach me despite me walking away and completely
ignoring him. I was invited by ICE and also told to bring MKN.
Were weapons involved? Yes. Selfie stick, glass cups, spit, and
alcohol bottles.
Will the children present? No. This is insane. This is half of
these are lies. >> Wait, which one of these is lies?
This sounds like a lot of from Zena. Wait, these are things that
happened. There's Zena's side of it, right? Zena might have been
like arguing with him or she might have gone and re-engaged with
him at certain points here. But like I I didn't hear like a lot
of actual lies there. suspended threatened to hurt or hurt you
before >> on or around 5:22 >> May 22nd >> 522
Darius stalked me to Dallas Tech that physically assaulted me
on video with documented evidence he continued to follow me around
various buildings and continued to assault on me in various threats
even >> like this is just true for how the TwitchCon stuff
went isn't it sorry Kitcon stuff went all of that was like them
was that Zena chasing him down I I thought that was Darius mostly
following her around >> he continues to stalk me via social
media and speak about me and had people contact me for him. When
have I done that?
He even joined a public event I was hosting just to be around
me to harass me again, which is on video as well. Is she talking
about the prison >> I think this would be some other Ice
Beside thing. Welcome, Raiders. Welcome. >> On July 4th,
he continued the assault by arriving at another event he knew
I was attending where he continued to approach me despite me
walking away and completely ignore him. I was invited by ICE
and also told to bring MKM.
Were we involved? Yes. Selfie sticks, black cups, fit, and alcohol
bottles.
Will the children present? No. This is insane. This is half of
these are lies. This is so stupid, bro. >> The day of the
court date. Just make sure you tell the judge that she's a felon
who carries mace around. >> What he wrote in here?
>> Look at how she describes these
>> So, to get this, this application isn't getting granted.
that just matter of fact I'm going to keep I'm going to stop
after this like in >> bro I dude you can support like I
feel like you can support 80% 90% of this with like clips like
there are literally
>> with it the application isn't getting granted cuz it's
literally stuff I can just show the videos of what happened
>> does he think he looks good in a lot of these videos
>> and it's it's ins it's absolutely insane and also I
can show the messages that I was invited I wasn't stalking anybody
an event I was hosting you weren't hosting the prison stream.
You were an extra that was there for one day. Two days.
What a disgusting
>> A lawyer. >> Do I even need a lawyer for this?
>> Do you still want to get back with her
>> You're probably going to need a lawyer for this. Well,
you could just you could just say, "Oh, well, the protective
order actually doesn't with me and not fight it, right?" If he
just goes and says like, "Hey, this didn't happen, but I'm not
like I don't really care about fighting this, but here's my proof."
>> Should he leaves her? No,
>> it was temporarily granted because of your DV case.
Just talk to your lawyers. Stop talking about it on stream, [__]
>> She's pro talking about when you guys met up again at
Ice's house. >> Yeah, that wasn't an event she was hosting
either.
>> This means you can go to Ice's events. You're cook,
bud. >> No, I just won't invite her. >> Looks like
you want to go to Miami. >> That actually might be true.
Darius kind of blown up right now. >> That might actually
be true.
Darius blown up. He's making it happen. What's up, Tree? How's
it going? >> Hey,
can you hear me? >> Howdy. Yeah, I can hear you. What's
up? >> Is this temporary protecting protection order or
is this like a Did they go to court yet? >> I think it's
both. It's I This is This is both the service of the court date
and I believe it's a temporary order as well. Like, so so I think
he already has to surrender his guns within 24 hours and stay
away from Zena.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Why does he have to give away his
give up his gun? >> It's like they're It's like the Travis
County rules or something for a protective order. They have to
like give back the the process server said it to him when the
process server served him. >> Is it So is it safe to say
it's done now or or were he still like I love you? >> No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Um he was reading earlier
and he was like Zena in one of them says he assaulted my friend
and I or my friends and I and he's like well at least she didn't
say boyfriend. So I don't know if you could read between the
lines on that one. It's um >> oh my god this is crazy.
Oh let me let me get in your I'm not going to stay long but I
want to watch this with you. >> Okay. All right. Okay.
lies. And if I show this to Ice, he's just gonna be like, "Damn,
>> Ice ain't gonna do nothing. >> Get granted in
general." >> Well, he said he said Ice just isn't gonna
invite Zena. And I'm like, "Uh, well, I don't know. Dar views
right now, but I think he's going to invite the content and watch
it happen." >> Wait, wait, wait. Sorry, sorry, sorry. He
might be right because didn't didn't uh Ice and Zena have a little
back and forth
over his girlfriend or
um Didn't Ice and Zena Yes. Yes, Zena was like Zena is good friends
with Ice's ex-girlfriend and or sorry, current girlfriend. I
actually don't know if Kimmy and Ice are together anymore. They
I don't I didn't get the sense they were breaking up after that.
It seemed like Ice didn't want to break up. So, yeah, but Zena
took her side and Ice was pretty Zena. So,
>> Yeah. Anyway, so I he might actually for that reason
I totally forgot about that, but that might be a reason that
he doesn't want Zena around. We'll see. >> I think >> the
lawyer will get the charges >> there. Ice said it was all
fake. Oh, Ice did say that he Ice said that he made all that
up. It was so dude his his walk back of all this he said about
his girlfriend was weird and less impact. >> So, wait a
minute. So, the fight with Zena was staged. >> No, it wasn't
staged. He said he made up about his girlfriend. I don't think
he I don't think he took back the about Zena.
>> I don't think the protective order can get granted right
now. It's an
>> So, none of this is granted into the court case, right?
>> That banned me for mentioning your name. Imagine banning
anyone from her channels. She desperately needs
>> Right here. >> All you have to do is show that
she's lying about some of the things. >> It's a temporary.
>> She got video footage cuz you guys keep stream streaming
[__] She She could probably prove most of the stuff
she >> This is the problem is he's like, "Oh, I can just
show the clips." And I'm like, "You Yeah, the clips don't make
you look good. The clips are of you like hitting her and biting
her and spitting on her.
>> Like the clips are not good. I don't think I don't know
why he thinks the clips go in his favor. The clips do not help
him. >> Partiate order. What does this even mean, dude?
What's a temporary party order, dude? >> Yes, it says
>> temporary exparte. I forget. Exparte means without representation.
So temporary order. I think I think exparte is without representation,
right? What is an exp partee order issued by a judge without
prior notice to the other party and without them being present
in court? Yes. So it is without you being represented in that
court hearing. >> I want the blue, dude. Damn. >> So
it's a temporary order and they will have So it's a temporary
order. So temporary restraining order and they'll have a court
hearing on July 30th. So in a week. >> Oh, that fast.
>> Yeah. So well I think this is like a pretty big deal
is when you get a temporary restraining order. They had enough
evidence that a judge was like, "Oh, I think this is actually
like really bad and I will order this really >> Aras, if
she may if this becomes permanent permanent, you're dude.
>> because hold on, let let me explain why I say that,
right? >> Yeah. Sure, sure, sure. >> Cuz Dena is
a streamer and so is he, right? and he like and those two have
been like cross
they have been in each other's um
streams as well as the circles of the streamers Ice and the other
people. So like and let's be clear the only reason Darius is
in with these groups is because of Zena.
So he will have to stay a certain amount of distance away from
her which is going to cut off a lot of his collab opportunities
because if Zena >> if Zena is there especially if Zena
gets there first and she'll make it she'll make it a point to
get to any of these places first. He can't go near her. He can't
go any of these um events. He can't go into these restaurants,
any of the clubs. If she's there, he can't go there. And and
Zena Yeah, >> will with him and see if he say yeah. So
if Darius is like, "Yeah, me and and my boys, we're going to
go to the we'll say the Hippity Hoppity Club, right?" She's like,
"Oh, then we're going to go to Hippity Hoppity Club. I'm going
to go there, too." And then she'll get there first. And then
she'll basically say, "You can't be here." Or or somebody sit
up here and show Dar Darius that she'll she's there and he has
to leave or else he'll get arrested. >> Yeah. The really
up thing actually is um she could technically just even if there
were ICE events, she could technically just go like hang out
there. Like I feel like if they're doing stuff in Austin, right,
and it's somewhere she could go, >> then yeah, she could
just be around and he would be
>> I'm sure
>> Yeah, he probably get a lawyer. >> Yeah, there
you go. You took the words out of my mouth. That was my turn.
>> I was going to say he can stop that by getting a lawyer
to argue on that behalf that this is part of his job. And they
these two are on the same platform, kick.com, and they roll in
the same type of circles and therefore need to make exemptions
for that so that he doesn't go to jail. So, he's going to have
to spend money on a lawyer to if he wants to protect himself
from Zena using this, you know, in her favor. >> Oh, man.
I I just he can get like a lawyer. I don't even know how I don't
know how he fights this. If a judge saw these facts and like
I'm going to grant this based on these facts, then I feel like
there are clips to back up like almost all of it.
>> Yeah, I agree with that. What I'm saying is that like
if she turns this permanent, you can have stipulations in in
there saying like, hey, this part is my job, right? So for example,
let's say for instance that both of them worked in the office
of kick and therefore she had a restraining order. Well the judge
can make an exemption can make an exemption for that with his
lawyer. He needs a lawyer to say the proper um language, the
proper court language to tell the judge like, "Hey, these two
work in the office building of kick administration
and you know he can't stay 500 or 1,000 ft against her cuz he
away from her because he has to show up for work." Well, then
the judge will say, "Okay, you two can show up. Um, you two can
be at the same workplace in the kick administration building,
but don't say nothing to each other and talk to your boss to
make you sit on one end of the building and she sit on the other
end of the building as long as within the confines of the duties
that you two have to perform for kick.com. >> Well, I So
that's how it would work in office place. How is it going to
work for like the actual they do >> if he gets a lawyer?
This is this No, no, no. This is what I'm saying. This is a specific
this is a different case. So he can get a lawyer to argue on
on similar to those bases, but I'm not a lawyer. So, I don't
know the language that the lawyer used like these men these men
and women learn a lot of of the loopholes that that you know
that's why they get paid the big bucks to basically make that
possible where this can't happen and he can be able to go into
like if Ice Poseidon has a uh event and he invites Zena and Darius
the lawyer can argue on Darius um side of Yeah. Well, they can
stream and you know what I'm saying? Like he he would have to
have the language to to argue on Darius behalf. >> What
is he gonna do it for like every event? That's crazy. That would
be like so expensive. >> No, for just streaming. No, no,
no. I mean, no, no, no, not every event, but just saying like
I stream. This is what I do. This is these are the people I hang
around that she's friends with. These are this is the area that
I'm known to to uh to stream at. And
I sorry, something just struck me. You keep you finish. You finish.
You finish. >> And and that and that way I if if she she
can use this against me to basically cause me financial harm
cuz I'm not going to be able to work. >> Yes. But he could
argue all of that. Okay. I actually think here's the thing that's
I think is actually going to happen. I don't think the Ice Pesidon
community, the like IP2 community, like these all all these people,
all the CX streamers, I think if you file actual like legal charges
against people and file like I don't think they honor those.
I think they basically say if you filed it, get the out of here.
I think that's like isn't that broadly understood between all
of those people? Like, hey, we're not going to invite you to
any of this if you try to get the cops involved.
>> I I don't watch ICE, so I I don't know. You You would
have to tell me. I don't >> Am I Am I crazy? I feel like
I feel like that's got to be the way it works. No. Yeah. Some
people He did that to Burger Planet. Okay. Darius calls the cops
and his roommates every other day. Darius doesn't call the cops
on his roommates. He calls the cops on like Murk and but Murk's
not in their community. And calling the cops, I don't know if
that's quite as bad. I think it's like the the actually making
it so other people can't do content. Yeah. Anyway, we keep we
keep listening to him talk about it.
>> You should not talk about >> Make sure to tell
the judge he showed up to your house without your permission
the night of the party. Reacting to this can be considered harassment.
>> I know what to tell the judge. It's just like insane.
>> Collect clips of her assaulting you. >> X party
means the judge only heard her
>> Yeah. So what am I supposed to do? So if you only hear
someone's side, it's granted. So am I allowed to talk about this
right now >> on your court date? Yes. >> Dude, that
none of that none of that is relevant. Sorry. I don't I don't
think he's absolutely allowed to talk about it. He what? He just
can't contact Zena. Like he he just read the thing. Just read
the thing, Darius. Yeah, he's got a court date. >> Cursed
paper. Throw in the maggotinfested dump bin. Out of sight. Out
of thought. Big brain move.
>> Wish you well, Darius. Best of luck. Wish you well,
Darius. Best of luck. >> What's going on with his hair?
What is those lines in it? >> Do not talk about her at
all. I just assume he got some stuff carved into the side of
his head. Maybe it's like uh
I don't know. I don't know if that would have been like community
participation or if he just thought it looked cool. I'm not totally
sure. >> Do not talk about her at all. Anything negative
you say can be considered a violation of the order. >> Don't
talk about it unless it's with a lawyer or until it's removed.
>> The more you the talk, the more you give evidence to
the other side. Consult your lawyers. that I would say probably
he shouldn't be sitting here like talking about it because he's
going to say something that's going to further incriminate himself.
That would be why he shouldn't talk about it. >> Looking
out for him, too. That's these are good advice. This is good
advice they're giving him. >> I don't know if he's going
to listen to it, but >> he got ringorm on the back side
is his own idea. Oh, he got ringorm. >> For real. Oh my
god.
>> How the did he get ringorm? >> I have no idea.
Yeah, I've not been following this guy that much, so yeah, I
got no idea. Oh god. Kind of gross. >> It won't be granted
until the court date. Call her and ask her if it's real or just
a joke. >> No, don't call her. The
>> That was Yeah, that was definitely a troll message.
>> Rooftop jogger. >> Renlux here. I just got back
from serving some bald guy. Back at home now in my fe grippy
socks petting my cat. What's up, man? like the
is just like annoying. I I can understand like doing it and being
like, "Listen, bro. I just feel uncomfortable. I had some happen
and I feel like it's just like [__] getting too crazy.
It's fine." But it's like these are like >> This is literally
the only contact this
>> and I
saved them all, but I didn't click them. >> Has he never
has he never gone back and looked at these streams and seen how
bad they look? Like they
like unironically like with not a lot of like without malice
they look so like he is just standing there spitting in Zena's
face repeatedly. >> Yeah, that was really bad. That was
really bad. So when I saw that I said that's that's the end of
them now. It's official. There's no way they're going to get
back together after that. >> Yeah. When he's at Kitcon
though as well, he's like chasing them down. He's like chasing
her and Shuy down, right? Like he's walking after them. Like
it's it's bad. His side is bad. >> Do this in like what
is it? July 30th. 7 days. Bro, >> that's next week. Wow.
That is that's like uh I think that's next Thursday. >> I'm
just going to call Ice. >> Tell Ice Shuy has a part in
this. He terrified Aiden will want him to box >> I know
Shuy does. Dude, he told he told Zena to do it first off. Shuy
literally told her to do this. But it's whatever. It's fine.
Yes, dude. I'm calling Paul.
>> who's Paul? Who's Paul? >> That's Ice Poseidon.
That's Ice
>> sorry. I was just going to say it's like it's up that
he's like, I need to call my my father a father figure. Okay.
I need to call somebody I look up to right >> It's very
forced Z knew to write that garbage while his massive throbbing
was deep inside her fat dad. >> Shuy and her are trying
to get banned from the event Miami. I'm going to tell Ice and
then just do what he said cuz I mean like dead like I don't want
to like >> Oh, do we get an answer on this? >> Hello
Paul.
>> Let's see. >> Hello. Wait, can can you hear me?
>> Yeah. What's up? >> Hey, do you see did you see
what just >> No. What just happened? >> Okay, so
I just got served
a protective order paper. >> Doesn't even like her cousin
clip. >> 90%
also doesn't like >> she won't be allowed. >> Dude,
90% is false stuff. Trey, you you like kind of know his stuff,
right? You kind of know what's going on with Darius and stuff.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Like we should just go back real quick and watch where
he like actually explains what it accuses. Like he reads out
some of the things it alleges >> I was hosting. 522 Darius
stalked me that Dallas Tech physically assaulted >> Here,
hold on. It starts like right
>> That's what she wrote.
Suspend. The applicant further asked the court to suspend the
respondent's license to carry a handgun. >> Damn. Oh.
>> Oh, damn. >> Oh my god. Prohibit the respondent
from taking, harming, or interfering with the care, custody,
or control of the following pet. And her response to is, "We
have dogs and cats in the house and use mace and tear gas bombs."
That's what she wrote. >> Huh? cuz she thinks we're going.
>> So like uh I think she's basically saying that although
I don't want custody of the animals, they're like abusing animals
in the house or something by having them there. >> Oh,
come on, Zena. I know you're not trying to take his dog away
from him now. That's a little bit low, right? >> That's
what I That's what I said. I was like, if you're trying to take
like uh GMO away, that that would be
his name is
>> That's [__] up. We thought that we could
be current partners,
something. Oh, she kept her phone number the same.
No. What did she say happened?
>> Here we go. This is where he actually reads it. >> I
live stream and I have several videos of him stalking me and
following me and physically assaulting me. I also now have a
case in fluger after he spit on me and assaulted me and I pressed
>> The citation XYZ.
>> He has since contacted me off fake text app numbers
and via Discord in various communities I am in in order to get
my attention. He has physically assaulted friends I am with as
well. Hey, at least you didn't call him a boyfriend. >> Dad,
wait a minute. He's not calling Merc his friend. Oh, he's calling
Shuby. Okay, never mind. Yeah, yeah, yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Was a weapon involved? Selfie stick and glass cup. Zena
is the one who hit me with the glass cup during that. >> So,
I don't know what the glass cup thing is precisely,
>> but the selfie stick thing did happen. >> Yeah,
I pressed charges, but he was not arrested. I called the police,
but she did, too. Were you injured? Yes. He bit both my breast
and fingers until I bled. The cops took pictures. She was on
top of me.
Has respendant threatened to hurt or hurt you before? On or around
5:22. 5:22. Darius stalked me to Dallas Tech and physically assaulted
me on video with documented evidence. He continued to follow
me around various buildings and continued to assault on me in
various threats, even via text messages. He continues to stalk
me via social media and speak about me and have people contact
me for him. When have I done
>> Oh, come on, Darius.
Uh, that last one maybe not true, but basically from what I'm
hearing here, I don't know about the glass cup thing, but like
90% of this is just true and like it's documented on camera.
And then he calls Ice Beside and he's like 80 90% of what she's
saying is wrong. I don't know how he >> he even joined
that I was hosting just to be around me to harass me again, which
is on video as well. Is she talking about the prison stream?
On July 4th, he continued the assault by arriving at another
event he knew I was attending where he continued to approach
me despite me walking away and completely ignoring him. I was
invited by and also told the >> You kept following her
though, Darius. You kept following her.
>> Yeah. He just I mean it's crazy how he keeps saying
like, "Oh, this this is wrong. This is wrong." And it's like
it's all on video of him following her around. There is, I think,
one part at the Kickon thing where Zena comes back and re-engages
with him that I remember that, but for like 90% of the time,
I feel like it's him re-engaging with her. Maybe 70% of the time,
80% of the time, it's definitely him re-engaging with her more
in the recent stuff. >> Approach me despite me walking
away, completely ignoring him. I was invited by ICE and also
told to bring MKM.
Were we involved? Yes. Stealthy sticks, glass cups, spit, and
alcohol bottles.
Will the children present know? This is insane. This is just
these are lies.
>> No. No, they're not lies. >> Yeah, I don't think
they're lies. Anyway, back to the ice besides
>> uh protective order paper. >> Doesn't even like
her cousin clip. >> 90%
also doesn't like stuff. >> She won't be allowed. I don't
I I'm going to have to fight this of course, but I'm like worried
and I'm mo most of it is like so like some of these say like
she was hosting an event and I stalked her at the event like
like you didn't like you didn't invite me to July >> Squeeze
wants to get back with Shvy >> the prison stream. She said
I stalked her at is there a way that I can get you to confirm
to me either on video or like a text message that those were
your events and not hers and that I was invited. It says that
you showed up
>> Yes. And these they said >> Wait, I didn't think
it said that. I thought it said that he showed up at an event
she was part of just to harass her. That he she signed Maybe
he signed up for it. Isn't that what it was? >> She was
hosting. >> I don't know.
>> Ignore him. I was invited by ICE and >> on July
4th, he continued the assault by arriving at another event he
knew I was attending where he continued to approach me despite
me walking away. Please ignore him. >> I was invited by
ICE. >> Yeah, but you don't have to I I don't know what
happened at that, but you followed her. >> Yeah, if you
followed her at this event when she was basically trying to deescalate.
Yeah, you can she can use that against you. So when someone is
walking away from you, they're deescalating and you're escalating
by following them. If that happened, I don't know about this
particular clip. >> Yeah. Well, he's just lying ice beside,
right? He's just making up like she didn't say this >> to
bring NKM.
>> Were we involved? Yes. Selfie stick, glass cups, fit,
and alcohol bottles. Will the children present? No.
>> Yeah. Let's see. I might have to back it >> This
is insane. He knew I was attending where
people contact me for him. When have I done that? >> So
there's that one. >> He even joined a public event I was
hosting just >> joined a public event I was hosting >> to
harass me again. >> So joined a public event I was hosting
just to be around me to harass me again. That could mean like
accepting an invite, right? Hosting. Yeah, but she might have
been one of the ho was she not a host for the Ice Besidon prison
>> which is on video as well. Is she talking about the
prison stream? On July 4th, he continued the assault by arriving
at another event he knew I was attending where he continued to
approach me despite me walking away and completely ignored him.
I was invited by ICE and also told to bring MKM.
Were we involved? Yes. Selfie stick, black cups, spit, and alcohol
bottles. Will the children present? No. This is in No. Darius
was a contestant and Zena tagged along with Shuy. Zena was the
one who was barely in the event. I thought Zena was like somebody
who was involved in the event, but I didn't watch it. So, if
you're saying that, maybe that's true. Hold on one second. >> I
didn't see that at all. I didn't the whole event where he had
the top of his head shaved and the rest of it. I didn't I didn't
even watch that entire event. I think I think the only clip I
saw was when she pepper- sprayed him and then she got caught,
you know, also with the pepper spray. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> When
he was handcuffed
the table. >> Zena was Yeah. Yeah. Zena was a guard for
like 2 hours and Darius was in prison for like 5 days. Okay.
But I don't know. Was she supposed to be there is the question.
>> Things and I came to stalk her. >> There were
the fights. I got the fights. >> At the events that she
was hosting. So
>> I mean Yeah. I'll say that. >> Okay. I'm going
to like text me. >> Hold on. Let's listen to this again.
>> At the events that she was hosting. Yes. in these they
said that she was hosting things and I came to stalk her at the
events that she was hosting. So like
>> I mean yeah I'll say that. >> Okay, I'm going
to like text me in a >> uh also um for the Aiden Ross thing.
Uh is this something that I should like have to bring up? >> Zeno
is there like 10 hours a day. I don't know what the these tards
are talking about as a night guard with chicken. Okay. Or is
it something I'm going to have to back out of depending on it?
Or can >> you sure this is a fireworks thing, not the prison
thing? Okay. >> He communicated to maybe Shuy to not bring
her. >> I mean, I can tell you that. Yeah. Um >> I
would appreciate that. >> Yeah. I mean, yeah, it's really
uh J of her to do all that. >> Did you hear what he's saying?
>> I mean situation. >> I can I can tell her Yeah,
I can tell her to do that, >> but it's not going to make
a difference. Yeah, I know. >> I know. Yeah, I party. She
literally showed up at my house and then she brought like tasers,
mace, and weapons. And she doesn't mention that anywhere in here.
It's just she says that I stalked her here and then I I bit her
for no reason and I beat her and chased her while beating beating
her with a glass cup, which is just not what happened at all
in any way, shape, or form. Uh, and then I'm also attacking all
of her friends associated with her, which again, Shu is the only
person who I've ever fought with, and he definitely attacked
me first both times.
>> What? That's insane. That's an insane thing to say.
>> Um, maybe you could say, was it? Sorry. He definitely
attacked me both time. Wait, what did you do both of those times
that made him walk over to touch you at all?
Wait, he's he's like not totally wrong, but like what happened
both of those times? Were you physically hitting Zena
both times? So,
>> I mean, yeah, you were invited to the events that I
did. So, yeah, I mean, I'll text you that. >> Yeah. Thank
you. I'd appreciate that. Uh I'm trying to figure out if there's
anything here that's like specific that's related to you because
she wrote stuff about the prison stream. Let me let me pull it
up. One second. Alcohol bottles. Like, bro, what? >> His
hair looks nasty. This looks terrible. I wish you put a hat on
his head. Crazy. >> He looks like um when bears and stuff
get mange, right? They're mangy bears. And you ever seen a mangy
bear? Mangy
>> A mangy dog, not a bear, though. >> Never seen
a mangy bear. >> It's got like the mangy bear thing going
>> It's just so distracting. Looks so bad. >> Got
like the mangy mangy bear going on. >> Yeah, I know. Not
good. It's not good.
You can just say whatever and
like you can just say whatever she wants on the restraining order.
>> Yeah. And the protective order is granted. So I'm I
don't think I'm allowed to I don't even know if I'm allowed to
or not talk about her right now until the court date and it's
kind of like ridiculous because
uh it's like this is like like I I kind of I accidentally got
served on stream. might even mean to get served, but I'm like,
"Oh, so now I get served and I have to now just be quiet about
it and just let this
like say whatever the they want because uh I guess it's like
based like it's not going to get granted cuz it's literally just
like like on here I'm not allowed to get like she put that she's
that uh sorry, she put that uh prohibit the respondent from taking
harm or interfering with her animals." And the reason she put
in here is because I have dogs and cats that could hurt them
and I could use mace and tear gas bombs on her. I'm like like
what? >> Wait, no. I think she's saying you are not safe.
Animals are not safe in your presence. I think that's what she's
>> Like
did he just totally misunderstand
>> Yeah, I think that's what he did
>> here because >> she's she's literally trying to
get your she's truly trying to get animal control involved. That's
what she's
trying to >> Hats that could hurt them and I could use
mace and tear gas bombs on her. I'm like, bro, like like what?
Like it's it's it's like I like and now now I have I'm like I
have to go to court. I have to go to like appear before a judge
on the 30th and I have to pay for a lawyer because someone just
said whatever the they wanted and the application I mean it's
not granted but it's still like >> you don't want this
to be permanent there Darius. That's the thing. You don't want
This is temporary. So, you have to stay away from her unless
something inside that restraining order saying you have to be
gagged, which you didn't say that. So, I mean, did he say he
has a gag order? That he did he say he's not allowed to talk
about it? >> No, I don't think there's a gag order involved.
I have not seen I have not seen a gag order at all. >> So,
you have to stay away from her. But the thing about it is is
that you have to get a lawyer so that it's not turned permanent.
Um cuz a permanent restraining order can be anywhere from 3 to
5 years.
Well, it's a it's a protective order is what it says. So I think
that would go through the case, right?
>> Protective order. >> Yeah, I said restraining
order. I think it's a protective order. So I think that go through
the length of the case >> Okay, then I I don't know then.
I thought it was a restraining order. Well, aren't they similar?
>> They would be very similar. Yes.
Yeah, he can talk about her. He just can't go near her. Okay,
it's permanent. She could tank his streaming career overnight.
We'll see. >> You don't have to That's what I said for
a lawyer.
>> Are you trolling? Would you hold on? >> I mean,
you don't have to You don't have to for a lawyer. I'll be your
lawyer. >> Are you troll? >> Did I I just said he'd
pay for a lawyer for him, so Jesus. That's Ice is really Zena.
Damn. No.
>> Would you go to court? I'll go to court and I will say,
"Judge, my client is innocent. You can do nothing." >> Oh,
he said, "I'll be your lawyer." Oh, god. Don't turn this into
content, Darius. Do not turn this into content.
>> Do not turn this into content.
>> Don't do that. >> Ice Poseidon cannot be your
lawyer. >> You actually want to try cuz it's a it's a we
could you could probably come up with me and you could pet the
pot. You could say that you were actually here during some of
these events that she's putting in at least a prison stream minimum.
And the she's also said, "I stalked her at the your Fourth of
July party." So that's that's what I was saying as well. The
Fourth of July stuff with MKM everybody. She said I was stalking
her there. Then that was event and she also put it as an event
that she was hosting. >> I will go there as your lawyer
and I will
I will make I will make you walk out not only as a free man,
but I will make her pay you reparations. >> Is that possible?
Can you counter someone for this? Like the idea of me having
to pay for a lawyer or having to use my
>> Also, Darius, she has this
on clips on the streams that you all have done. You especially
that last one in the what didn't that happen in the back of their
house in the yard with the whole >> There have been there
have been ones I believe since then that Shuy and Darius have
both been at. That did happen in their house. Yeah. In their
backyard, but there was like a fire.
>> I didn't Oh, I didn't know there were more. That's the
only That's the last one I saw. So the when I saw that one I
was like there she going to [__] your ass up. You
know what I'm saying? That right there is a case and she did
file it. So like stop thinking that she doesn't have a case.
Like she kind of does actually not kind of she does. My thing
is is that I don't know may
to me humbling yourself
and and uh you know just saying like look whatever you want I'll
do it you know let's let's just drop this and I'll I'll I'll
do whatever you want me to do stay away with this that the other
this is costing you money is it worth it is he making let me
ask you something you keep up with Darius is Darius making >> he's
probably making $20,000
a month or more
us. >> Okay. Then it's all going to go to lawyers then
because a lawyer is going to cost a minimum of 20. Well, it depends
on what the >> probably going to cost quite a bit of money.
Yes. Like his lawyers he's already gotten are probably eating
into his profits pretty significantly.
He's making 1k a day he said. Yeah. That's not shocking. But
he has to stream every day and I don't know if he's been streaming
every day. >> It's not worth it, dude. >> Well, I
mean it might it might be worth it. It's possible >> be
streaming like >> here's the question. If his if his job
is like this, I don't think you get I don't think you tax deduct
lawyer fees just because it was like related to your >> Yeah,
but he has a criminal case pending on him right now. Okay. So,
you got this and then you got I mean not you got that criminal
case and then you got this case. So it's to me I don't know maybe
I'm different because I don't like to with courts
and be in the system like this and like he already had a case
out of Las Vegas the first time and they gave you probate where
they really just gave you um a light sentence because you were
a first time offender. You're not a first time offender anymore.
So, like the more times you keep around with criminal court,
then it's going to get real serious for you in the future. >> Oh,
yeah. >> You want your you want your criminal history to
be like clean as possible.
>> You too, right? >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's what
I'm talking about. I'm like I'm I'm looking at all that that
he got criminal cases with. I'm like he's he's up his life for
content. Like this is not worth it. So, the money that he's making
is not going to be, in my opinion, is not worth it, >> man.
I
uh probably not. Yeah, I think it I think it just continues to
spiral downhill and then eventually it's going to start with
his ability to stream, right? Like he won't be able to stream.
He'll stop making money. >> Or like like for example like
if uh KCIP disappears tomorrow, right? >> Then
it's suddenly it's suddenly a big problem again. I would think
Merc stuff is the criminal stuff because the state is pursuing
charges. Well, I I think Brooke said she was going to go and
and testify as well. She wasn't >> She changed her mind.
I thought she said she was going to testify. >> No, as
of a couple days ago, I think she she turned it and said uh she's
going to
>> Can I Can I Can you sue for that? >> Yeah. Court
case is >> Yeah, but only if he's found innocent. He's
not going to be found innocent if they're not going to dismiss
it. If if if the judge dismissed this outright because of lack
of evidence, sure. But you don't have the money for a civil litigation
with a lawyer to sue Zena. You ain't got that. You ain't got
suing type of money. I don't know why people quick to say, "Can
I sue? Can I sue? Can I sue?" Y'all know how much a lawsuit,
a civil suit cost? >> About $50 to $200,000. >> Have
you been sued? How do you know that? Um,
the Pixie GoFundMe. >> Oh. Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Never
mind. Never.
My bad. I forgot.
>> It's just how I would guess. Yeah.
One time he should have called Destiny, calls Ice instead. Well,
if somebody has experience getting sued, it is Destiny. >> yeah,
that's a good point. Who said that? Whoever said it in your chat
is true. Like, he should have called Destiny, not no damn Ice.
>> Although, Ice has probably been sued, too. I'm There's
no way Ice hasn't been sued
really in his entire career. >> I don't but but let's be
honest, Destiny would give him sound legal advice versus what
Ice is talking about showing up as his goddamn lawyer trying
to get >> I just want content. Yeah, Ice is just farming
content for sure.
Yeah, Ice was present for the Zena is lying about in the document.
Like what anhydrris, what is Zena lying about in the document?
I don't know what we're saying like she's lying about exactly.
She's giving a biased accounting of events. I don't think she's
lying about stuff.
Uh maybe maybe you could argue that like one of those things
if she went to one of the events after finding out he was there
and there was proof of that, then I'd say she's lying.
Murk said she was lying. Okay. I I sure trust Murk's ability
to evaluate that kind of situation that she hosted the events
and then he was stalking.
>> He did stalk her at the at the Kickon in Dallas, Texas.
He absolutely stalked her. Yes, 100%.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Why are you Why would you even
cope and say that didn't happen?
>> Joseph came to his house uninvited. I don't think that's
true. I think she was uninvited, but I do believe she was invited
to the house or Shuy was. And I don't know if somebody is here
sitting here thinking you could invite Shuy and not Zena. Is
stream titles for 3 weeks ago are farming my ex? Yeah. Well,
>> also she said, "Do does the respondent possess or have
access to firearms?" She said, "Yes, I don't own a gun." Oh,
he doesn't own a gun. >> Do one of his roommates own a
gun? That would be the question, right? If he's got a roommate
there who's got a gun, then that probably could be a yes. >> I
only know one of the roommates, and that was the one we were
talking to the last time I was here, right?
>> Yeah, Legacy. Legacy don't have no gun. I know. He He
don't seem like the gun >> Like, is he too gay to own a
gun? Is that what you're saying, Tree? >> Is he gay if
he women?
I don't know. That's It's a difficult question. It's a difficult
question. Probably not.
Too bad a gun.
Something like that. Um, legacy once murdered a homeless man.
That is true. Actually,
>> Ice is trolling. >> I I think Ice is just going
to farm this. Ice farms everything. So, Ice is just going to
farm this for content as much as he can. >> But that the
guy came to me and told me I I had to give in all my weapon,
but I don't I don't own a gun.
Also, she said I bit her breath and her fingers until she bled.
She didn't bleed. And also, she was choking me. She was trying
to choke me and let Subie jump me. Like, yeah, I bit her. I bit
her. That's why I didn't go to jail. >> Dude, he bites
everybody,
>> I'm a woman and I don't even bite. >> He bites
everybody. >> Well, if you have evidence for all of the
things being lies, then that is actually illegal on her part.
And you can see she didn't she can face criminal
>> Yeah, that's what I was going to actually ask if like
should I be cuz I don't want I don't want to continue this in
general. Also, I don't want to pay more money on lawyers. They're
really >> That's what I'm saying. You talking all this
about money and lawyers. You talking a civil suit. You just don't
understand. That's more money, too. And they're not going to
do a pro bono. >> Yeah. No, they're not. Nobody's doing
>> pro. Listen, serious. Just leave. Like I told you last
year, just leave Zena alone. You two are just like like you guys
keep getting together and bad things keep happening to you mainly.
Not to her mainly. A lot of keep happening to you.
You're just a masochist at this >> At this point I mean
for quite a while. I mean as long as I stand corrected. >> I
stand corrected. >> Look at this. Look at this. Look at
this redact tattoo right here where he tattooed like onto himself.
He's always been a masochist. >> This is like literally
like his entire life. It really has been.
>> Yeah, I take that back. >> He continues to stalk
me via social media and speak about me. Okay, I do speak about
her, but that I don't think stalking me via social media. Your
social media is public. Anyone can go see that. I don't think
it's like >> like whatever. And has people contact me for
him? I don't think I've ever had Have I ever had one of you guys
contact Zena on my behalf?
>> I I
don't know. I don't I don't think so. I don't know. >> There
was a minute where you you think he's the middleman, but I wouldn't
say >> he he even accurate a middleman for like stuff that
she was trying to contact to me or >> I was like both of
you with like a one. >> She says he even joined a public
event I was hosting just to be around me and has harass me again,
which is on video as well. On July 4th, he continued to assa
he continued the assault by arriving at another event. He knew
I was attending where he continued to approach me despite me
walking away completely ignoring him. I did not speak to him
and he continued to follow me. Okay. Other part is >> I
mean to be honest all of this
>> and I think it would just get thrown out entirely the
moment you show the judge video of of the prison stream where
she like willing in >> I know
>> God I could never have people like this in my life who's
just going to like blow smoke up my ass and tell me it's a it's
a fog. Like you got to have you got this is why you should like
you should have called Darius cuz I mean uh uh Destiny because
he would have told you like well what the did you does she have
proof like this? He will actually question you and your cope
and say is this on stream? Does she have clips on this? And you're
going to like well yeah but see I it's there's more context to
it. Blah blah blah. Like
>> how do you Yeah. How do you explain
>> that you do a job that overlaps with her? How do you
explain that? And then also try to say that she shouldn't get
a restraining order because she was in one of the content things
or she shouldn't get a protective order because of one of the
content things you did. Like they're saying is saying, "Oh, if
you show her like walking in during the prison streams, then
obviously she wanted to do content with you, she was fine with
you, right?" But I don't know. Like that's a part of her job,
right? I I don't know that you can make that argument. You can
argue, "Oh, this shouldn't get >> But that's also that's
also irrelevant
>> Yeah. Well, it could be irrelevant. I'm just saying
that he's going to he's going to explain the exact reason he
wants the this to be like lifted for work or something is the
exact reason that like she would have been there in that room.
So that that like rationale is something they both have to deal
>> Yeah. He's going to have to get a lawyer for that though.
That's what I'm saying. like if cuz he's he one he's going to
have to prevent it from being permanent and two get a lawyer
to explain what his job is cuz you're going to have a boomer
lawyer that won't understand what a streamer is and what he does
for a living and how they're they're both of them are intertwined
together with the same type of people that they collab with like
Dar can you imagine Darius trying to break that down to a like
a 45 or a 55 year old uh judge like, no, he's going to have to
get a lawyer to explain
>> I don't know. We'll see if he can uh we'll see if he
can afford to beat
>> afraid for her life, you know? >> Yeah. And this
is all within the last 45 days, too. This isn't like Okay, it's
been like 3 months of like her like not doing anything or saying
anything toward me and I'm just harassing her. This is like like
July 4th was what, like 3 weeks ago? 2 weeks ago.
Like it's it's this is but it's just like it's dumb. And that's
what I'm saying. I'm mostly I'm mostly what I'm long term I'm
worried about is the Aiden Roth thing getting because I get I
just get there. Um and then also I have the citation I'm dealing
with. But I'm pretty sure I'm going to get I talk to my lawyers
I'm pretty sure I'll be fine with that citation from when she
was at my house and she brought tasers and ma or whatever. But
>> well, I don't even I don't even know what you're talking
about. But if uh yeah, I mean, if you prove that she lied on
the restraining order, then you can uh get her in trouble for
perjury, and that is a $10,000 fine. And uh then you can counter
sue her as well after the fact for loss of income.
I will I will probably have to look >> is definitely looking
and I'm also going to have to maybe pay for a lawyer depending
on how this goes on the 30th. >> I don't know. I'm >> You
don't have to pay for a lawyer. I'll be your lawyer. Don't worry.
>> Are you actually trolling? Like, will you show up with
me? >> I'll show up in my Louis Vuitton suit and I will
get you obscree.
>> Can you stream? Can you stream in court? >> I
don't think you can stream in court. I don't think you can stream
inside. You can stream outside in the court office. Also, I need
a suit. I
>> dude I could you imagine if if Darius goes to to court
and then it's just like no you can't be you can't be within like
X yards of Zena and he's just totally from like streaming any
of the IRL stuff from then that point onwards.
Could you
>> ice beside walks out of the courthouse and it's just
like sorry bro them's the >> tomorrow. You want to get
a tailor suit? >> I want to have a tail. >> Well
when when wait is this cork >> in seven days.
Seven days only the 30. >> I might not be around in seven
days. >> I might not be around either. I had to go to I
was supposed to go pick up my
>> Well, I mean, if I'm around, I'll uh >> I'll go.
>> I was I my computer shut down.
>> Yeah, I wasn't here. I was gone for the >> I was
gone for the last three minutes cuz my computer shut down. Let
me go back and watch the stream. >> Oh, damn it. Uh, hold
on. I'll just pull it back. I'll pull back two minutes here.
This himarius, I was just um Ice is like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll definitely go. >> I bit her. I bit her. That's why
I didn't go to jail." >> Well, if you have evidence for
all of the things being lies, then that is
on her part and you can she can face criminal justice.
>> Yeah, that's what I was going to actually ask if like
should I be cuz I don't want I don't want to continue this in
general. Also, I don't want to pay more money on lawyers. They're
really expensive.
But >> yes, you're >> I mean this is like literally
like he continues to stalk me via social media and speak about
me. Okay, I do speak about her, but that's I don't think stalking
me via social media. Your social media is public. Anyone can
go see that. I don't think it's like >> like whatever.
And has people contact me for him? I don't think I've ever had
Have I ever had one of you guys contact Zena on my behalf?
>> I I
don't know. I don't I don't think so. I >> There was a
minute where you guys using me as the middleman, but I wouldn't
say that's he accurate. >> Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Did
Did Princess literally just say, "Yeah, well, there's a time
you used me as the middleman." Did he just say, "Yeah, no, that's
true. That's pretty >> man." for like stuff that she was
trying to contact me or >> I was like, "Okay, both of you
like >> who's this talking? Who's this talking?" >> Princess.
It's Princess. >> He even joined a public event I was hosting
just to be around me and has to harass me again, which is on
video as well. On July 4th, he >> Oh, did he said it was
really? Okay. >> He continued the assault by arriving at
another event. He knew I was attending where he continued to
approach me despite me walking away and completely ignoring him.
I did not speak to him and he continued to follow me. Okay. Other
part is >> I mean to be honest, all of this
I think it would just get thrown out entirely the moment you
show the judge. >> Oh Jesus, I went back way too far. >> Dream
where she like willing.
>> I know. pepper spraying you. I mean, >> I pray
for her life, you know. >> Yeah. And this is all within
the last 45 >> Oh, never mind. That's that's just them
saying the same thing. >> This isn't like >> that's
just them saying we're I think we're into new stuff. >> Okay.
Like 3 months of like her like not doing anything or saying anything
toward me and I'm just harassing her. This is like like July
4th was what like 3 weeks ago, 2 weeks ago.
Like it's this is but it's just like it's dumb. And that's what
I'm I'm mostly I'm mostly what I'm longterm I'm worried about
is the Aiden Roth thing getting because I get there. Um and then
also I have the citation I'm dealing with, but I'm pretty sure
I'm going to get I talk to my lawyers and my I'm pretty sure
I'll be fine with that citation from when she was at my house
and she brought tasers and me or
>> I suppose I'm about to roll up to a procedural hearing
for a protective order and get Darius thrown in jail immediately.
Okay.
Like I don't know how it's going to happen, but he'll figure
it out.
>> Well, I don't even know what you're talking about, but
it's uh Yeah. I mean, if you prove that she lied on the restraining
order, then you can uh get her in trouble for perjury, and that
is a $10,000 fine. And uh then you can counter sue her as well
after the fact for loss of income. Yeah,
I will I will probably have to look into that because I'm going
to have to take off streaming and I'm also going to have to maybe
pay for a lawyer depending on how this goes on the 30th. I don't
know. >> No, you don't have to pay for a lawyer. I'll be
your lawyer. Don't worry. >> Are you actually trolling?
Like, will you show up with me? >> I'll show up in my Louis
Vuitton suit and I will get you obscree.
>> Can you stream? Can you stream in court? >> I
don't think you can stream in court. I don't think you can stream
inside. You can stream outside in the court office. Also, I need
to get a suit,
>> bro. We got to get Taylor tomorrow. You want to get
a tailor suit tomorrow? >> Have a tailor suit. >> Well,
what when Wait, what is this? >> In seven days.
>> Seven days. >> That's the 30. >> I might
not be around in seven days. >> I might not be around either.
I had to go. I supposed to go pick my
>> You said he may not be around in seven days. I said
that. >> Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. What did you say? I said,
"Don't know what I said. I was in the moment."
>> Well, I mean, if I'm around, I'll uh I'll go uh be your
lawyer or testify or whatever. Sure. I think it's funny. >> All right.
I'll bother you in seven days, then. I I appreciate I appreciate
your assistance here. >> Although, if you go to jail because
of me, you can't blame me. >> I'm not going to jail. It's
a restraining order. So, it's worst thing that will happen is
I can't talk to her or whatever, and I don't care. I just >> I
think it's funny content at the point where it is. I don't think
it's like I'm not dying to talk to her,
>> but okay. All right. I'll uh I'll talk to you then,
I guess, or during the >> All right. Thank you, Paul. I'll
message you about I'll message you about the proof of that later.
>> Hi, Paul.
>> Bye. What? >> You didn't get hide back. Thank
you for letting Mr. Dino Paul Ice Paul will be at my side
and we'll probably get this denied but it sucks that >> Paul
to cope what
>> him and I beside Listen I hope he gets confident. I
hope he gets confident. He might be confident enough to to try
it. All right. We we put it on the calendar. We'll mark it on
the calendar. July 30th. Okay. >> All right. >> We're
going to we're going to be ready for it.
It might be content.
>> It might be. >> Me, too. I always love Darius
content. I haven't been able like I've been busy. As a matter
fact, I got to go because I gotta um
I got to decide if I'm going to do a video on C. I just did a
stream on Candace. So, I don't know if I'm going to do a video
or not. Let me see if I can find something else. But if I can,
>> she lies so blatantly. It's actually
>> Did you hear this [__] say? Did you say
on her show, I'm being sued? That's how you know I'm telling
the truth.
And then she's like, and also they were contacting me and my
lawyers the whole time saying, "If you don't take this stuff
down, we're going to sue you. We're going to sue you. It's defamatory.
We're going to sue you." >> What do you think about this
suit? Like, like she literally acts like the suit is a surprise
where she just said that they've been basically asking her, they've
been sending her cease and desist. They've been telling her to
take it down to like stop with Breijit. And she was like, I didn't,
this came out of nowhere. I don't even know. I I can't even believe
I found out when everybody else found out.
It shouldn't be a surprise. Like what? >> It shouldn't
be. And yet somehow
it continues to seem that way to her. Um I thought the the funny
thing was she pulled up quotes from the lawsuit and just lied
about them, right? Just lied and said, "Oh yeah, she just lied
about like all of the all of the things they were saying like,
oh, she she you know, um she made comments about blood liel."
She did. She said like, "Oh, this this like people." She was
like, "Christians all over Europe would go missing and it's like
tied back to Jewish people." This is like a verbatim quote from
her. Uh what was the other one? There's stuff about gang. She
like she said all the things they said and she just lies and
says she didn't and you like Google it and you just find the
clips like >> of her just she's just blatantly lying. >> I
think like right now she's this is what I think what she's doing.
She is actually appealing to the court of opinion. Well, not
court of opinion, her her fan base, her dumbass fan base. And
I think that that they are probably set out of court unless they
want to embarrass her. Delaware is very blue
and you have a a thriving black community in Delaware. Candace
don't want this [__] to go to trial. The
so crazy like like you your your corporation is in Delaware even
though you live in Tennessee and the UK. So that's where the
court case would be and you're like okay we want you know uh
Breijit said that she wants a No. Who decides that they wanted
a jury trial? I think No, no, no. She just the Macrons said that
they want a jury trial, right?
>> Yeah, if they filed the complaint, they would have.
Yeah,
>> say they want Right. Candace hasn't responded yet. And
I believe that she's probably gonna like uh do a uh um she gonna
set out a court and one of the stipulation is they're gonna she's
going to have to delete the videos. She's going to have to, you
know, issue a retraction and make an apology
about what she said. Um, now she has a very big ego, so that
may not happen. And she may just go down kicking and screaming
and act like a victim and she probably like say that and then
get get the either way either way her reputation is going to
be. It just depends on how is it going to be because she's going
to uh
settle out of court and then she can play the victim like I had
to. You guys, I can't really talk about it because of the lawsuit
and because of the of the contract I signed and the agreement
I signed, but trust me, I I some things were being threatened.
She can play that victim or if they drag it all out in court
on a jury trial, we get to see all the goes down and make good
money off of it. Then it makes her look bad. Either way, she's
going to look bad, but she'll look worse with the trial
um versus
settling out of court. >> I don't know if they'll I wonder
if they even want to settle at a court at this point or if they
actually just want to go and like show that like I feel like
if you get if you get some level of discovery on Candace, I feel
like you're going to eventually find that she discussed all of
this stuff in the open like that she knew she was lying about
>> right? I feel like almost certainly.
>> Yeah. And I also wonder how closely her husband's tied
to any of their entities because I
>> I feel like if you could sue them as one joint financial,
but I'm guessing he's got like a prenup that separates their
>> Yeah. And and he just wanted he just wanted babies from
her. You know what I'm saying? He's gay. He just wanted like
to have a nice family.
>> Biracial kids. >> She's uh she's still financially
set. Like she could literally get ruined and she's still financially
set. And and a lot of people keep saying that, but I don't see
her getting financially ruined because she filed I looked this
up uh on online cuz I said this lives in Tennessee and UK. Why
would she throw uh incorporation? Why would she have her corporation
in Delaware? So I looked it up. um you could do the same and
most of your um Fortune 500
uh companies are incorporated and registered in Delaware because
of
>> uh liability of it. >> Yeah, there you go. Thank
you. So, it's like that it's a camp. So, there's only so much
you can take. There's only so much you can sue for.
>> I see. >> So, she but but but here's the deal.
She got money. I I don't like Candace, but I'm not going to lie
about this is not like loaded. It's her reputation means more
to her than money. And and I'm saying this as a right-winger
like when she off the Trump supporters and mega when she picked
off the
when she off a lot of people and people were like you Candace
and she needed to she needed something to get people on the right
uh to come and like love her again. And let me tell you something,
these love a good conspiracy theory. And so when they notice,
and I'm just going to be, let me just be very honest.
Michelle Obama is a biological woman, right? But we on the right
like to with her and say she a man, right? So we we know but
but see Michelle Obama
is like when they go low, we go high. So that's why, you know,
the right keeps with her saying she's a man. See, so Candace
had this mentality of, "Oh, I could do the same thing with Breijit
and accuse her of being a man. Not only is she going to go high
and not do nothing about it, but she's French. These never met
a white flag they didn't like. They ain't going to do." And so
to all our surprise, they did do [__] cuz we didn't
think nobody in in in France ever with somebody in in America
on a civil civil suit. This is the first. So this kind of like
took everybody's surprise. So it was like we she thought that
uh Breijgit was a easy target. I did too,
but oops. Guess not. I uh I did hear though that apparently Bridget
the Macron's like um
their their defamation case that went in their favor apparently
got overturned in France. I have to look into that and see exactly
why that >> Yeah, because it's in France. I don't I don't
I don't know and didn't look into it. Yeah, it was overturned,
but they did appeal it so it's not over. >> Okay. Yeah,
I need to Yeah, I need to figure out exactly what happened there.
Reje McCron takes it to the highest appeals court.
>> Two women were acquitted last week of spreading false
claims online that she had been born a male. Okay.
All right. >> All right. Let me go and figure out what
I'm going to do for my political channel. I uh at least I saw
I went and came here and I saw you was talking about Darius and
I was like, "Hey, I get to come in again."
Oh, so what the was this? I got to fill out a form. I got to
agree to this form in order before I come in here. What was that
all about? >> I have no idea what you're talking about.
It's my They're like rules for entering the Discord. Maybe if
you hadn't been doing it for a while, maybe you had to like fill
something out. I don't know.
>> I don't know why that happened, >> but there there's
like
>> No, I didn't do anything, but um there there's like
a thing to enter the Discord, I think. Yeah. >> No, it
didn't pop up to me until I had to enter Oh, maybe maybe it was
a Discord itself. I thought I I thought it was when I tried to
enter into the voice call, this little thing saying you can't
use slurs, you cannot do this, you cannot uh violate the rules
of this
>> and you cannot be transphobic and all this. I was like,
damn, godamn the
>> They um they did a voice check and they heard that you
were black and they were like, we need to remind her. Good thing.
No transphobia, no homophobia. We know it's a problem.
All right, I'm going. Uh, goodbye JS chat and you my chat. Bye
JS.
>> Talk to you later. Bye. Whoa. Okay guys, I'm gonna we'll
come back to this another night. We ran out of time a while ago,
but I didn't want to kick Tree out or anything cuz obviously
I love talking to Tree. So, I was waiting
Was it waiting? I was just I was like, I'll talk to Tree and
then I'll end after that. So, love you guys and I'll be back
tomorrow. Okay. Have a good night. Bye-bye. Good night. See you
later. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.